so yesterday was asked on a podcast pad
when did you know you were gonna win
like what you know you were gonna win
I'm by the way this is a very common
question but there's a reason why people
ask this question because what if I told
you you already know whether you're
gonna win or not let me state I won't
work out what if I told you you already
know whether you're gonna win or now let
me explain to what I mean by this
it is 2006 I'm in a meeting speaker
speaking please deliver this message and
I'm sitting right there and I probably
wonder top 30 top 40 guys in all but all
of a sudden for about five minutes
I sewn out I'm nan Durham I'm physically
in Durham that an or mental you ever
done that before like you're not you
know what I'm talking about right so I'm
out I'm gone and my brain just goes to
my mind is like where am I gonna because
I was 26 years old at the time so what
am I gonna be you know five years from
now 10 years from now 15 years from that
in my mind all of us and I got the smile
on my face but it's not as smells like a
smirk on my face right and all of a
sudden I snap out of it cuz I'm hearing
my name and the speaker from stage is
saying everybody to look at Pat's eyes
and everyone starts looking my eyes says
I don't know what passed thinking about
but sounds gonna happen with Pat sighs
and you know what's wild about that
meeting she was what I was thinking
about the entire time when I snapped out
of it because everybody was bragging
about what they were gonna do but I knew
most of the guys that were bragging
about what they were gonna do they were
all full of it in my mind I said and I
know this is gonna sound military you
may be like the wrong words but just
award we used in competition of sports
still want you guys in this business
I'm gonna kill everybody in this
business and they have no idea what's
about to take place because I only not
going to stop especially I'm not gonna
stop just because in what is same but I
have a sense of peace of the world in
myself saying there's no way to go about
stopping with this don't want to like it
every thing I came for all of it I
wanted all of it I'm 26 at the time I
wanted every I'm making 150 I'm not
making a lot of money you're at the time
but there was that confident so watch
what I did next I said okay Pat and you
know how you talk to yourself I'm like I
like your confidence where you're at but
let's see how much real confidence you
have what we should go to somebody that
is way ahead of you and tell him that
you're gonna be bigger than them
let's see if you have that kind of guts
so I went to Phoenix I throw out the
Phoenix and this guy was speaking it was
the biggest kind of company at that time
and he was a bit of a bully and I like
bullies because I know how to deal with
bullies and so I went after this guy and
I said hey I just want to tell you
something when I talked about sat for a
few minutes it's like 10 15 years older
than me said yeah sure I said I just
want you to know a lot of respect for
the business you build but there's no
way in the world you will ever build the
size of a business that I'm going to
build and it's excuse me I said there's
no way in the world you ever gonna build
a sense of the business I'm gonna build
now you can call it cocky you can call
it arrogance it can call it whatever you
want do what you call it I didn't care
about how I came across I didn't care
about you know oh my gosh this guy
selves know all I knew was I wasn't
going to stop it just wasn't going to
stop so watch what happens next
I leave I come back I get to work and
the next thing you know things start
happening things start elevating but
here's what's crazy a lot of times
people come and ask the question did you
always know I pretty much knew that I
was willing to pay the price to get
everything I wanted because you know we
had a baby I never forget we had a baby
and my wife no way speaking should have
been handle all these kids and all the
semester listen the people can become
president and have kids and raise kids
and run businesses and do all this other
stuff and people going to military we
can do it as well if only one person
that it's a different story but about
107 billion people according to some
senses have been born in this world
since day one that's the number you read
about a hundred seven hundred thirteen
billion people a lot of them have that
kids we can overcome that challenge as
well there's not only been one
billionaire there's been millions of
millionaires it's not a big deal there's
not only one billionaire there's been a
ton of billionaires it's no longer a big
deal to the billionaire moral the story
is whatever you think whether you're
gonna win or not the reason why I say
you're right because deep down inside
you know whether you're gonna what
you're willing to pay the price long
enough or not you already know it nobody
else knows it it's a decision you've
already made by the way it's a secret
decision you and you nobody else knows
it's like it was a secret decision to me
like if you watch a Kobe documentary or
a Georgian documentary or some of these
guys is documentary that they killed it
they knew way before they won that they
were gonna do what they wanted to do so
for someone because that alright now say
man I would love to get to that front
you can't you can but it's all about
clarity it's all about you can never be
very clear about exactly what you want
I'm showing a habit of you continuously
being able to overcome pain like talking
to a guy Diaz and I said listen why is
it every single time something happens
you stop working why why is it every
single time you have a family you're
sure you have a health issue somebody
dies you almost look for an excuse to
slow down your business and you say but
you don't have some what I'm going
through it's so hard and you want
everybody to feel
sympathy why do you do that yourself I
see you realize that's a mechanism
escape of escaping from the work to
actually go out and get the dream and
this is your way of saying because I've
had such a hard time that's why I never
won that you're escaping it just so you
know that like the performers you know
like we know somebody else may not know
but we no no no it's not really how it
is I really have a tough life come on
man and then I give ten other tests and
when it's about tough lies I'm like you
know you just like negative attention
and you got to figure out a way to stop
that because it's hurting so whoever's
watching this there's what I do know
someone in the world
one of you is watching the same as
speaking my language I'm going to win
I'm going to make this thing happen
I already know it test I relate because
I'm one of the tolerate came if that's
you and I wait to read about you and
instruments take everybody have a
graduate love